[Music]
[Applause]
Rich Eisen NFL Network host and host of
the Rich Eisen show on Roku and uh NFL
game day morning also the Rich Eisen
show Monday through Fridays at noon
Eastern on Roku he'll be on the call
Jags bills in London kickoff will be
9:30 a.m. eastern and Ricardo joins us
from London how long do you think you
would be in London before you would pick
up a British accent I think uh you know
I'm I'm uh I'm going to have to stay for
a while for that you I still have the uh
I still have the New York accent in me
Dan you just have to cut me off in
traffic for that to happen Okay um I
just got to London about three hours ago
so Cheerio mate you know I'm just uh
it's gonna have to by the way it sounds
like uh Paulie's gonna have to turn
vegan based on what I just heard yeah
the um I mean this is a pretty big bet
that uh they they put a lot on the line
with meat Friday and then the Bears um I
don't know if you're covering this on
NFL game day morning but it it seems
like it's a pretty big deal that uh the
Bears against the commanders who do you
like to uh I like the commanders Dan I'm
going on a very thick limb on that one I
I like Sam Howell and his bed head and
the rest of this team uh certainly
against the Bears on a short week where
um where where I don't know what in the
world they're they're the most
disappointing team of 2023 as far as I'm
concerned I know there's another 0 and4
team I know there's a lot of one in
three teams that might take that but for
them to stick with Justin Fields get him
DJ Moore make these changes and now
coming tonight 0 and four short week
looking at 0 and five um that's I didn't
I didn't expect that to happen but see I
look at the Bengals as more
disappointing than the Bears because the
expectation was the Bengals could go to
the Super Bowl yeah but I I guess the
caveat there would be the injury that
burrow suffered in the summer and them
having to make the decision to uh sit
him were not sort of the Jamar Chase
plan to keep him out for the first month
of the season and now they have no
choice yeah looking at the first month
of the Season where you have to figure
would they have gone one and three with
Jake Browning you know and so here they
are with that horse sort of out of the
barn he doesn't have an injury
designation this week so maybe they're
they're speaking it into existence
because he certainly doesn't look the
same to me yeah I said this a couple of
weeks ago if the doctor said he will be
you know measurably better than sit him
down until the bye and and you know
maybe he could be healthier now but you
watch them play and he's holding them
back he can't throw the ball over 10
yards he's not I mean most of his
attempts are under 10 yards and that's a
pretty good explosive offense and you're
not able to utilize Iz that so um would
you get in a hole in your division
absolutely if if he didn't play until
the bye but is it going to matter if if
after the bye in that division you know
Baltimore might be the class of that
Division and I just don't think playing
Joe burrow now you got to go to Arizona
Arizona is frisky so no guarantee that
they're going to win that game and the
Ravens if they beat the Steelers they're
not only uh on top of the division uh
with three division wins all of them
would be on the road they've already won
at Cleveland and at Cincinnati and this
would give them a win at Pittsburgh and
a huge leg up yeah just five weeks in
but listen um you know this is a
wideopen conference I think it's a
wideopen league um you know obviously
you got the Niners and the Cowboys on
Sunday night just to see if the Cowboys
can measure up um to a team like San
Francisco but uh I I really do think
it's anybody's
league for for a great handful of teams
Dan you got an idea of who the Jags are
and who the bills are going into this
game on Sunday morning I don't have I
have a much better sense of who the
bills are I mean you've seen it the last
three weeks um and the um the Jaguars I
just don't know um we're seeing them
Saturday morning for the first time and
they'll have a significant advantage of
being the first team to play a second
consecutive week in London and the bill
are getting in um today they're they're
Landing just now so that is a an
advantage just in terms of the game but
in terms of Jacksonville and who they
are no sir um I I don't have that sense
but the bills have won three straight
games in boat rate F Boat Boat Race
fashion and um I I do believe that they
are the best team right now in the AFC
you want to call them the most complete
team the team that's got um a leg up and
pro bowler all over the all over the lot
um and and certainly if they played the
Chiefs right now I think the Chiefs
would have a significant disadvantage
Rich Eisen will be on the call coming up
on Sunday morning the bills and Jags
kick off at 9:30 a.m. eastern also his
show Monday through Friday the Rich
Eisen show at noon Eastern on Roku most
valuable player on the ners team is who
uh I'm going to I'm going to go off the
board here Dan I'm going to say Brock
pie I'm going Brock py here not just
because of the way he's playing but
because of the way that he's playing you
don't hear the words Trey and Lance ever
anymore end of story whatever the Niners
gave up for Tre Lance whatever they uh
couldn't get out of tre Lance normally
that would send the coach and the
general manager to the unemployment line
instead they both got contract
extensions yeah that's because Brock py
plays the way that he plays also the
value um is is not just figurative it's
literal the amount of money that they
get to pay so many others because of the
contract he's the he's the last pick in
the draft doing this Dan and so he is
terrific and I know mcaffry is scoring
like crazy and I know Fred Warner and
Bosa are doing what they're doing on
that side of of the ball but Brock pie
is just
spectacular and uh we just so many
people don't believe it because he looks
like he's going to a a civil engineering
class instead of coming for you and your
defense and I think we're going to see
it again Sunday night yeah I agree with
you he can be the most valuable player
on his own team but Christian McCaffrey
will be in you know consideration for
the MVP League wise but what kind of
numbers I mean it's a Quarterback Award
but could you see numbers that if
mcaffrey puts up this and this that he
could be the MVP I think what you do is
you know voters will just split it
there's an offensive player of the year
award and so so that's usually the the
MVP that's not a quarterback I know it's
the compound it's the compound it's a
total compound but they that's the way
the the voters normally do this sort of
thing Hey listen uh again you you cannot
discount the way that pie is playing and
how he has taken uh the pressure off the
lid off if there was such a thing I
don't I don't think there was because
Jed York loves his coach and his general
manager and for good reasons but the
fact that you know Trey Lance you trade
up all that to go take somebody third
overall and he he's not ready to play
and you go ahead and you have Brock pie
to play take a look at what the Jets
Zack Wilson was taking a pick before
Trey Lance and the Jets are hopefully
gonna get uh another good game out of
Zack two consecutive games from Zach
Wilson of significant leadership and
play they haven't had that yet and the
Niners are starting 40 with Mr
Irrelevant if you will being the most
relevant player for them I believe
that's you know I and that's fully
understanding what mcaffry is looked
like 18 touchdowns in his first 18 games
as a Niner that that I would say is a
significant uh contribution DP we uh
broached this topic yesterday uh if I
sent fritzy to Bill bellich che's press
conference yesterday and he asked the
following question yes in spite of all
the winning and all the Super Bowl
trophies what would you say to those who
say you're on the hot seat right now
Bill how do you think Bill would is that
a fair question to ask
bellich that how would you so ask it one
more time because you need to
really make sure first of all it's not a
yes or no question which is what for
some reason everyone asks Bill bich
about 80% of the time yeah so that's a
that's a good uh sentence sentence
structure give it to me one more time in
spite of all the winning and all the
super bowls and everything you've
accomplished in New England what would
you say to those who say you're on the
hot seat right now with the
[Music]
Patriots just you know just preparing
for New Orleans and you know they have a
tough defense and you know that's for
you guys to decide by the way this is an
actual sound this is Rich doing as Bill
bellich yeah that was it I thought
that's not what you didn't want me to
role play D we role play but I didn't
know if you that's basically what his
answer would be I mean he would you know
he just you know Str first of all I
think that would lead
to what's the over under on the number
of awkward silent seconds there I would
say probably a good four to five you'd
hear room tone you'd hear a lot of good
room tone yeah you'd hear the buzz of
the lights and maybe some air
conditioning Vents and then he would he
would he would answer that way but let's
say they went five and 12
Rich yeah now then then what would
happen yeah uh I I would definitely
think that uh Robert Craft would have a
conversation with Bill bich that uh
would be a coin flip whether they are
still uh employee and employer that it's
entirely possible that bellich check
would be done in New England at 5 and 12
and going in a completely different
direction but how how important do you
think it is for Robert Craft to have
bellich become the all-time Victory
leader while being his head coach in New
England oh I think it's very important
but you know how many times in our in
our world do we see you know teams
staying together with their U player or
coach for the sake of a milestone and it
doesn't really help things in the long
term in the long run so and again I I
don't know what belich che's desire
would be to to stick around there
anymore or what a five and 12 season
would would lead to for him uh honestly
nobody can really read that situation at
all that said um they do have some
winnable games on the horizon and I just
cannot believe the team that we saw get
eviscerated by the Cowboys is the the
way that things are going to go the
problem is though you know now they come
to think of it Matt Jon's out and so is
their their stud rookie but um put it
all together I I think there's a good
chance they're still 500 in a couple
weeks Dan good uh H oh I just
interrupted your goodbye I didn't mean
to do that Dan did I did I disrupt your
flow yeah go there kind of finish your
thought and then then I'll I'll do it
again no I asked you if you thought that
they were done good to talk to you
rich good to talk to you all right DP
take care of yourself all right Rich
Eisen from London he'll be on the call
coming up uh this weekend early well
early for us 9:30 a.m. eastern it's Jags
and Bill also Rich his show the Rich
Eisen show Monday through Friday noon
Eastern on Roku